le quai de chargement ici que s'est
grandement occupés dont les studios de
mail cité du cinéma pandémie ou pas ici
ça tourne à plein régime
un bien terminer l'année 20 avec
beaucoup de productions qui était déjà
sur le site et on pense pour 20 21 qu'on
devrait avoir une année charnière
le montant des investissements étrangers
dans les tournages et la conception
d'effets spéciaux québec étaient en
hausse constante avant la pandémie
après une courte pause forcée des
activités ont repris de plus belle si
bien que le volume des investissements
étrangers pourraient se chiffrer à 1.2
milliard de dollars en 2023 excellent
début d'année
si ça n'avait pas été la pandémie
l'engouement autre secret du succès les
scieries pour la télé ou pour les plate
formes de diffusion continue qui sont de
plus en plus gourmande sas et
mondialement la tendance
la filière audiovisuelle représente près
de 20 mille emplois directs au québec
le plus grand syndicat des techniciens
se réjouit que les productions
étrangères soit de retour avec des
restrictions de voyage mais c'est très
difficile maintenant pour les
productions américaines de quitter
l'amérique du nord
alors ils ont tendance à concentrer leur
activité sur ce territoire
et c'est sûr que le québec devient une
option de choix parce qu'on reproduit
très bien sûr qu'à une ville d'europe
l'aide financière accordée par québec
traiter un autre bon coup de pouce qui a
permis de stimuler la production locale
la décision du gouvernement du québec de
dd la production québécoise absorber un
peu les coûts rattachés aux mesures
sanitaires sa définitivement aidé je
dirais bien même qu'il ya certaines
provinces au canada qui nous ont envie
depuis le début de la pandémie le temps
passé devant les écrans à regarder des
films et des séries ont considérablement
augmenté
ces séries tourner dans la métropole
nous permettront de regarder des
contenus tourner ici ici n'est bien
lexandre chartier radio canada montréal